[Music]
we did it we defeated racism and all it
took was black panther finally a black
superhero we've seen that before but a
big-budget comic-book movie with a lot
of black people in it we've seen that
before but it made a lot of money yeah
and it's actually so good the Oscars try
to create a new category so that they
could give it an Oscar this is getting
kind of weird ok years from now you
might be looking back at this thing what
the hell was I talking about
but the hype around this movie was crazy
both before and especially after it came
out people act like this was the
Schindler's List of superhero films like
there was never anything better will
never be anything better we did it we
reached perfection and me being the
sniveling jerk-off I am of course had to
go yeah that's good
I may even go see it again I say that
not because I saw anything majorly wrong
with the film but I saw it almost
reaching that epic level and kind of
pulling back at the last minute which is
fine it's still a good movie
I just never quite got on the bandwagon
like everyone else as you probably
remember from Civil War Black Panther is
a superhero who tries to fight for
justice it also turns out he's a prince
though who's now being appointed to King
from where you may ask the land of
Wakanda a technologically advanced super
world whose technology is kept from the
rest of the earth why they feel the
world is not ready for such technology
and that mankind is just a little too
well goddamn crazy
what kind of does seems to have crime as
well but its culture is a lot heavier
and the people seem a lot more peaceful
that is until an enemy from the past
named kill monger comes around played by
Michael B Jordan one of the best if not
the best Marvel villain we've ever
gotten he thinks we'll Candace should
not only open its doors to the rest of
the world but it should invade attack
kill those who abuse the power they have
as the story goes on we find out he
actually has the possibility of becoming
King and challenges black panther to a
duel huh for such a peaceful culture
it's a very strange way of working your
government from there of course there's
action technology sidekicks big armies
all that cool stuff there's easily a lot
to like in this film number one again
being
for me the villain he's very
identifiable you know why he's doing
what he's doing and you even almost
agree to it like many great villains he
just goes that one step too far but
you're kind of following him on all the
other steps or at least you identify
with where he's coming from his acting
is so great too
you get an idea that this guy from the
streets wouldn't really fit in with this
cast that talks really big and epic and
has this grand language but he just
walks in like he always owned the place
and immediately takes command in charge
and he's just amazing truth be told the
side characters really upstage the main
character in this which i think is kind
of a problem not that the main character
is bad or unlikable or annoying or
anything he's just kind of dull he's not
really Black Panther that often you
don't see him go through that much of a
huge journey in terms of learning what
it means to be King and getting
responsibilities and so forth he just
kind of seems like the nice guy trying
to do the right thing which is fine but
the movie is called black panther I want
to know more about Black Panther I want
to find him more interesting there's a
scene where he's at his lowest plane and
he's practically banished some even
think he's dead and I thought well this
will be like a great Moses story he'll
go through all this realization and
he'll go through the spiritual journey
and he'll come back and he'll learn a
lot and I guess he kind of does but they
don't really put that much focus on it
again I remember the side-characters
journeys through this moment more than I
do his journey the effects of this movie
are also not very good surprisingly that
is to say what Conda looks amazing
anytime they cut to the city it just
looks phenomenal I'm assuming this is
where all the money for the CG effects
went because the rest of the CG looks
really bad
thank God this movie does have
interesting ideas and characters because
if it just relied on the action that
really wouldn't fly even the big climax
if they really want to make this huge
they would have had black panther and
kill monger like on the top of a tall
temple fighting against a sunset
something crazy like that but no it's on
these fake looking train tracks it just
looks stupid this is an epic this is if
Marvel did straight-to-dvd movies and
even the big battle happening above what
the side characters doesn't seem
especially epic because some of their
motivations we don't even get or the
connections with other characters
I mean there's a scene where the captain
the guard says to take out like the new
captain of the guards and they had kind
of a connection but they didn't really
dive into it much so yeah I want it to
be 100% on board with this I want the
shout this is epic this is huge but a
lot of those little distractions to
constantly get in the way for me I feel
like if they cut out a few other
elements like maybe the Andy Serkis
character we could have had more time to
focus on these people and sort of relate
to them even more
but again the ones we do relate to we
really relate to and the issues and
problems they bring up are good issues
and problems and they lead to a lot of
interesting questions I also do get
where people are coming from when they
say this is an important movie because
yeah there are movies out there comic
book movies that star black people but
not usually this many and not on such a
grand scale so it is nice to get that
representation but I don't think that
makes it an instant masterpiece when
there are very obviously some clear
problems with it that got awful problems
but enough to take notice nevertheless
this is still a very enjoyable movie and
does do things a little differently than
other Marvel films at least in terms of
the issues and ideas it brings up he
still ends with the traditional Marvel
climax is still has the typical Marvel
jokes but the look is very different the
culture is very different and like I
said before some of these dilemmas are
very different it's still a really good
movie and I really really recommend it I
want to see even more in fact I'd love
to see a black panther two three four
I'd love to see more of these characters
I'd love to see how they develop like I
said I didn't really feel Black Panther
himself was all that interesting maybe
we can really make him interesting maybe
we can find out even more about him and
what kind of guy he is
so I take check it out but let's face it
you already have checked it out well go
ahead and check it out a few more times
to see what works see what doesn't and
hopefully get a lot of black panther
sequels in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
you